iranienne était active sur les réseaux
sociaux son militantisme a fait d'elle
une autre victime des manifestations
elle est morte le crâne fracassé sous
les coups de matraque de la police
depuis bientôt un mois la révolte
s'intensifie en Iran après la mort en
détention de Massa Amini
femme vit liberté un slogan pour la
franchissement des femmes
cet élève ingénieur d'une université au
nord de l'iranic les lois islamiques
n'ont plus d'emprise sur la jeune
génération il veut plus de droits pour
les femmes parce qu'elles doivent se
battre pour tout
ces espoirs reposent sur la progression
des mouvements féministes au pays
sur des jeunes femmes comme Mika 16 ans
qui brûle son foulard devenu elle aussi
une triste égérie de cette contestation
et la disparu pendant plusieurs jours
avant que la police ne demande à sa
famille d'identifier son corps
[Applaudissements]
désormais la contestation s'étend à des
revendications ouvrières comme ici dans
une raffinerie de pétrole je suis faim
ou les hommes sont dans la rue les
professionnels sont dans la rue les
artistes sont dans la rue les sportifs
sont dans la rue et tout ça ensemble
fait que ce n'est plus la révolte d'une
classe ce n'est plus la révolte d'une
partie de la société c'est la révolution
de toute la société
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
de terrain à sanendage capitale du
Kurdistan les manifestations sont
réprimées dans le sang
discrimination qui est ciblé
c'est-à-dire qu'on va identifier les
leaders pour les arrêter et qui est
aussi cyber c'est-à-dire que le régime
est devenu très bon au fil des années
pour utiliser des outils virtuels pour
asseoir son pouvoir en fermant
l'Internet
[Musique]
cet enfant de l'Iran a disparu mais son
visage à l'instar d'autres continue de
nourrir la résistance
et de faire tomber le voile sur ce qui
se passe dans ce pays ici Yasmine Khayat
Radio-Canada Montréal